[Music]
[Applause]
Justin Hartley raises $10,000 for
charity on Ellen today Plunkett for
nearly three minutes with Ellen on his
back wow that's impressive
if you fall so Justin art leave
Instagram you know he's a plank master
he's a very strong and muscular man and
tonight on this is us
Justin's making fans sweat for an
entirely different reason Oh getting hot
in the Pearson household his budding TV
romance you are expect plenty of
surprises tonight as Kevin's steamy new
relationship with girlfriend Zoe
suddenly gets chilly I don't want this
really nice really late really a lovely
thing to be serious you know he's in
this new relationship so will that be
good will that be bad okay so Meagan
Mark little tiny hand
and Kate's secret is out I'm a heroin
addict
after mom Rebecca discovers her
daughter's hidden fertility drugs I've
had personal friends who have gone
through the same thing Kate's constant
struggle with weight hits close to home
for show creator Dan Fogelman he wrote
The Pierces sister loosely based on his
own sister Deborah who's a consultant on
this series Chrissie seen at firsthand
how much Kate's fertility issues have
touched fans a woman approached me and
she said that Kate story is her story
but she didn't have a happy ending and
she wasn't able to have a baby and she
said I hope it's different for Kate and
told me but speaking of Kate's future
fans got worried when older Toby wasn't
wearing a wedding band in this scene but
Chrissy assures us future Kate's
I want all white beautiful silver gray
here and I'm not continued for a fact
that I'm not putting on the leg
I love the whole process so I'm excited
for it
[Applause]
[Music]